been or not she knows that they were put
in for too long alice
was given a life sentence
and you spent about 22 years and
uh for something that today a lot of
people wouldn't even be going to jail
for
and it was uh it was horrible
and we found out about it and we gave a
commutation
that means we were able to get alice out
and she has been just so outstanding and
i'm so proud of you and
we're giving alice a full pardon i just
told her
we didn't even discuss it we just you
were out there i saw you in the audience
last night
and i asked the folks if you could bring
alice over we're going to give a
full pardon we're going to do it right
now that means you have been
fully pardoned that's the ultimate thing
that can happen that
means you can do whatever you want in
life and just keep doing the great job
you're doing
alice has done an incredible job since
she's been out
and
so alice it's a full pardon it's been
signed
you might want to keep that one
and here it is
[Applause]
pastor please you'll take that darling
let's pray together father we thank you
for the remarkable story of
alice johnson a strong believer in the
lord jesus christ whose life was filled
with
heart and life jesus christ our savior
it's in his name that we pray
amen thank you thank you mr president
for this example
thank you very much i appreciate it
alice thank you very much and
congratulations
thank you real honor to realize
congratulations
thank you thank you everybody thank you